three headlines that did not play out  but it's not as crazy as you think it's  not that these three headlines from  Engadget Yahoo and this newspaper were  so crazy wrong about the fact that the  iPhone would fail or that Facebook would  never make a penny with  or it was a fad  it's why and it's a huge thing for all  of you so many people lack the patience  to let [ __ ] play out  so many of you are going to give up on  your business on a relationship on a job  on a concept on an idea about an  investment because you have no [ __ ]  patience these  journalists these Publications had no  patience they wanted to make a quick  call they wanted to deploy cynicism they  wanted to be right when in the face of  short-term data that maybe show them  they may be right  the lack of patience the lack of  thoughtfulness the lack of understanding  of a long game is [ __ ] up a lot of  people